So far, we have seen different algorithms
for read mapping.
The next question that we are going to ask
is whether we can model a particular DNA sequence
and we don't know anything about DNA to predict
what it is and what is its function base on
certain aspects and certain models.
For example, if we have a new sequence of
DNA, what can we do to find out for information
about the sequence.
One option is to align it so that we can do
a database search and infer what have already
been known about the similar sequence.
Another option is to visualize it so we can
inspect the content of the DNA whether it
has a nucleotide composition that is very
different from what we are supposed to see?
Does it have certain k-mers which are existing
in higher frequencies than the others?
Is there any recurrent pattern that we observed
in the DNA and so on.
The third option is to model the particular
sequence.
Modeling refer to the situation where we can
make some hypothesis about the sequence.
For example, are there any common ancestor
for the sequence?
Are there any particular functionality associated
with certain regions of the sequence and so
on.
By modelling, we are trying to build a generative
model which is a mathematical model that will
allow us to predict different functionalities
of this DNA.
Given a long sequence of DNA, different regions
of the DNA play a different function.
For example, some part of the DNA can be an
exon, intron, promoter region, CpG island
and etc.
By building a generative model, we will be
able to identify and annotate these regions
given a new piece of unlabeled DNA.
Of note, the generative model must be able
to infer the functionality of non-identical
sequences and recognize the pattern of known
sequence.
Once the model is developed, we can classify
the non-annotated sequences based on the annotated
regions.
These generative models are often generated
by probabilistic modelling.
Why is it useful to have a probabilistic model
for the biological sequences?
First of all, biological data is often times
noisy.
Data collected from different sources may
give rise to various variations due to biologically
variability.
The probabilistic modeling techniques can
be very useful in updating our previous knowledge
that we already have about the biological
sequences.
When we are using probabilistic sequence modelling,
we are not limited to yes or no kind of answers.
Instead, it generates answer together with
the level of confidence.
One of the probabilistic sequence modeling
that is commonly used is called the Markov
models.
There are classic Markov chains and there
is also extended models for Markov chains
which are called hidden Markov models.
A classic example of a hidden Markov model
is shown here.
In this model, we have three different nodes,
represented in circles.
The arrow marks from one node to another node
are called transitions or edges.
In this example, it is a hidden Markov model
to describe the weather of a particular day.
We see that there are different transitions
between sunny whether to cloudy to raining.
For example, a transition from sunny to being
cloudy is 0.15 meaning that if a particular
day is sunny the probability that the next
day will be cloudy is 15%.
The hidden Markov models are applied in different
biological sequence analysis.
For example, hidden Markov models have been
used for predicting genes.
If we have a new sequence and we want to identify
the genes inside that sequence, we can use
hidden Markov models to annotate the regions
first and then identify the location of a
gene.
Hidden Markov models can provide very good
genetic models for performing different dynamic
alignment algorithms for pairwise as well
as multiple sequence alignment.
We can also use hidden Markov models for building
a profile for a sequence family, base calling,
determining DNA sequencing errors, prediction
of the secondary structure of protein, identifying
copy number variations and many more.
In other words, hidden Markov models are very
important mathematical models that have been
applied in various biological sequence analysis.
Here, we are going to look at a very simple
example of how we can use Markov chain to
model the CpG islands.
In the genome, the frequency of CG dinucleotide
occurs in low frequency.
For example, in the human genome the GC content
is about 42%.
So, we should observe G and C with probability
of 21% in frequency for each of them.
If we consider this as the expected frequency
of the bases G and C, then the expected frequency
that we should observe the CG dinucleotide
CG is about 4.41%.
But in reality, we observed only about 1%.
What is the reason that we see this type of
lower frequency of CG dinucleotide?
This is because naturally cytosine is chemically
methylated to methyl cytosine and methyl cytosine
is easily deaminated and converted into thymine.
The C to T conversion is very naturally occurring
in the DNA.
As a result, the observed frequency of CG
is much lower than the expected frequency.
The methylated CpG residues are often associated
with gene regulation at the promoter and exon
regions.
However, it is very interesting to note that
there are some regions where this methylation
process is suppressed, particularly in specific
regions near the promoter or the transcriptional
start site of many genes.
These regions where methylation process is
suppressed are called CpG Islands.
In the CpG Islands, the GC dinucleotide appears
relatively more frequent compared to the rest
of the genome.
So, identifying the CPG Island can be very
useful in identifying different genes.
Here is the problem.
Given a short stretch of genomic sequence,
can we decide whether this stretch of genomic
sequence come from a CpG Island or not.
To solve this problem, we need a model that
generates sequences in which the probability
of a symbol depends on the previous symbol.
Here is a graph structured model and the Markov
chain model for the DNA.
The graph shows 4 different nodes: A, T, G,
and C. Within these nodes there are certain
transitions which denotes the probability
of a particular nucleotide following another
particular nucleotide.
By calculating the transition probability
of each node from known CpG sequence vs non-CpG
sequence from the dataset, we can construct
the table of transition probabilities as shown
here.
For example, in the “+” or CpG-island
dataset, the transition probability from A
to A is 0.18, A to C is 0.274 and so forth.
It is interesting to note that, the probability
of CG is higher in the CpG model vs the non-CpG
model.
This is expected as the frequency of observing
the CG dinucleotides in CpG island is much
higher.
Once we have obtained these models for discrimination,
these can be used to compute the log odds
ratio by calculating the log of the ratio
of the probabilities for the plus model and
the minus model.
In the table here, we show the beta values
which are represented as bits.
We can also plot the data where the x-axis
represents the bits, and we can can see two
different areas.
The sequences the dark gray represent the
CpG Islands whereas the lighter gray areas
correspond to the other regions.
Thus, we can use two different Markov chain
models to identify whether a particular sequence
came from CpG Island or not.